human beings are driven by story
but what is story stories are metaphors
for life without story life is um
unlivable
there's no one better literally no one
on the planet more expert when it comes
to the subject of story than Robert
McKee stories are equipment for living
you see the full spectrum of life beyond
anything we could possibly live by the
thousands Robert is a master of the form
who wrote The Definitive book on the
subject called of course story but he's
best known as the most sought after
screenwriting teacher in the world the
wonderful thing about story is it's a
museum and you can go back you know to
the greatest of writers it's all there
waiting for you and every one of those
great works is as valid today as it was
when it was written we discussed his
friendship with Stephen pressfield who
tagged along for the experience which
was great we talked about Robert's
philosophy of teaching story what
stories are why they're important for
Humanity and just so much more including
the absolutely incredible behind the
scenes story of how successions Brian
Cox ended up portraying McKee in the
oscar-nominated film adaptation I don't
have any bloody use for it so with that
let's type interior podcast Studio day
into our screenwriting software document
hit enter and enjoy this Unforgettable
conversation with screenwriting Legend
Robert McKee
Robert it's an honor and a privilege and
a pleasure to hold you captive here
today so many questions for you yes
um you're you're somebody I've revered
and and
followed and and uh respected from afar
for a very long time I've got my my copy
of story here as you can tell it's it's
it's it's been through
sometimes here it's well worth it I
think it was 90 I don't know 97. yeah I
think I think it was 97 when I got this
book yeah I got it when it came out
first year yeah and I dug it out today
I've read it many times uh so you've
rented space in my head for quite some
time and uh it's it's a pinch me moment
to have you here and we also have
um Steve pressfield here as well I love
the fact that you guys are friends that
make sense to me it's beautiful to see
you guys together
and uh we're here on uh the precipice of
the conclusion of your career teaching
these seminars you've been doing this
for like
50 years 40 40 years you got a couple
more dates and then that's a wrap yeah
yeah I started um
doing these um uh in the uh when I was
40 years ago when I was in my early 40s
and
um
uh it just it took over my life
you know what in real real way yeah and
um
[Music]
put my life in a whole different
trajectory and um
uh
and this this uh fall will be the
farewell tour of the this is the last
time I'll do la New York London and
um and I'm going to do a Budapest hmm
and as a the government's invited me
there as has the Israelis and so I'll be
in Tel Aviv as well and so that's five
three days or four days if I do genres
yeah the way we do them here like here
in L.A in New York and London and so um
um
it's going out on a
high note on a high note yeah I mean how
are you feeling about it is it is it
Bittersweet are you excited for it to be
in the rear view mirror at the end of
this chapter and the next chapter look
like I really can't say until it's over
and I look back and um uh whether uh
there'll be any regret
um I don't think so
um
I know it's going to be sad I mean
without question yeah half of my life
has been consumed with um this this
teaching and uh developing the the
seminars and uh not just on story but on
on love stories and and crime stories
and long-form television
Etc uh and now
what I'm doing is I'm writing story two
and I just just published you know a
couple weeks ago yeah the action a book
on the action genre right and um and but
the next one
is I'm going to take story which is
still selling it's amazing but it it it
it hasn't lost a step and uh after 25
years and uh uh but I've learned a lot
in 25 years
and so I'm going to do story two which
will be
um uh a different angle on on story
and I'm going to uh look at it
emphasizing creative spectrums
what does that mean
every every
uh element that a writer wrestles with
um can be seen on a spectrum of choices
so you can be as minimalist as you want
or as maximalist as you want and every
variation in between
you can put the you know tell the whole
story over a kitchen table between two
characters
or you can do you know Game of Thrones
right okay
um and you can be as realistic as you
want or as unrealistic non-realistic
fantasied
um as you wish and you can stretch
reality from the most naturalistic to
the most fantastic
and so every element of story
uh is it can be imagined
as a on a spectrum of choices
from the from the most to the least from
the biggest to the smallest for the
brightest to the darkest the nauticals
um because uh what I want to convey in
this in story two
is choices
um
people
um you know I went out of my way and
when I wrote Story one
to introduce the book and say look this
is not a book on how to tell a story
this is a book on what a story is
and you need to understand all the
elements of story their relationships
and how they they combine to create a
story and that the possibilities are
endless
well that's not how people often read
the book
and they want to be told how to
and so even though I say I'm not going
to teach you how to they still want to
think okay right so now story two
because I understand they're desperate
it's it's Monumental this task
and making sense out of life
and to do it in a way that has insight
and and power and beauty and it moves us
emotionally and uh makes us laugh
it said you know it's it's frightening
uh when a young writer thinks I'm going
to
tell a story sure they want they want
you to hold their hand and walk them
through the process of the doing right
and you being a hard-boiled son of a
[__] quickly disabuses
you know that only that only that only
seems to encourage them to
um uh to go yes he's being tough but I
you know I'm I'm determined and so tell
me how right all right so I decided in
story two I'm going to be very clear
there will still be people who will read
it as a manual
there's nothing I can do about that they
want if they if they want it to be a
manual then it's going to be a manual
for them okay but I'm going to be very
very clear in story two that
uh it's choices
and
story two
uh like um
uh the books I've done on character and
dialogue
um I after um
Story one I decided I'm not going to
teach
for screenwriters only
um I never wanted to in the first place
in fact I had a fight
with my publisher uh uh Judith Regan
Harper Collins yeah iconic yeah okay yes
Queen of the best sellers
and um over the title
and she wanted me to call it
screenwriting
and I said no I don't want to call it
screenwriting I will use films for the
most part as examples because that's
what people know
um but and I'll put screenwriting in the
subtitle
but what I want to teach is story and
I'm going to call it story and so we did
that so
um so story two will be for stage page
and Screen got it so story two isn't an
upending of the principles that are set
forth in story it is story being you
know the what and story two being a
little bit of the how but more an
expansion of the principles elaborated
in story no I I I hope it's less of the
how
you see when when you when you say to to
someone
this is what it is
okay
these are the elements these are the
relationships these how they can they
work together to create whatever if I
was teaching music
I'd say this is the 12 note scale
this is These Are chords right this is
Beats this is rhythm right these are the
components of music
um you would never for a moment think
that oh now I can compose music sure
somebody explained to me the elements of
music
if you were teaching uh painting and say
Here's this is the rule of thirds this
is perspective this is the psychology of
color these are the components of
anything that goes inside of a rectangle
right and nobody would think oh now I
can be an artist
but for some reason you know when you
say these are the components of story
uh uh people think oh now I can I I that
I will follow that in some kind of
prescriptive way and now I can tell
story and what they discover is no they
can't mm-hmm the Mastery of these
elements in the in in conquering this
this this form takes years
trial and error success and failure and
mostly failure
and it's it's really really difficult
and that you know so they they don't
last right the dilettants get weeded out
right yeah so um story two is going to
make it even clearer than Story one just
how
it it he how
um how much uh variety
of choices you have in every single
aspect of it um
and I'm
I want to write and I'm also going to
use
the clearest
simplest light uh language I can
create
um
I I want
that when readers when they read the
book that
just lights go on story is such an
interesting terrain to explore and very
tricky and Elusive because story
operates
you know as as part of the fabric of
what it means to be human like we're
everybody is familiar with story we all
are on some level some version of a
Storyteller we tell stories about
ourselves and who we think we are we
tell stories to our friends it is in so
many ways
a big part of what makes us human and
yet the deconstruction of what story
actually is and the elements of it are
are very difficult to understand
well like and and there's a huge
difference between you know the story
you tell your friend and really
mastering the form and the Art of what
it means to tell a great story so you
know maybe I I want to disabuse people
of the idea that this is going to be a
conversation just for screenwriters or
writers like I want to talk more broadly
about how story operates in our lives
and why it's important to kind of
understand story and and you know how
that relates to You Know The Human
Condition
stories are
first of all metaphors for life
and so unlike music which is only
dealing with sound
um poetry which is dealing with feelings
uh painting which is dealing with what
you can see or imagine abstract or
concrete
the story is bigger than all that
and it's a it's a metaphor for life and
so
is is complex and difficult as life is
to understand naturally uh story which
is trying to be
expressive of life
um
is is
[Music]
needless to say difficult to to
accomplish
and um I I've gotten to a point now
where
I don't think
we have a story problem anymore what do
you mean by that I mean I see these
wonderful TV series
not so many films but and and I read
some superb novels now I mean the the
great novels have always been around but
um uh
uh but I see great storytelling
especially streaming long form
um and so I think you know uh
I think I've had some effect I think
I've helped I hope it's I I hope I have
but it seems to me that the the quality
of Storytelling uh certainly on um on
the small on the television
um is better than ever yeah I mean it's
unbelievable what's that I mean I don't
even I'm reluctant to even call it
television I don't know what you call it
now
because the television has that you know
it's an old word and um and it has all
kinds of associations
um
but it seems to me that the that the
quality of Storytelling is is good now
or better now than it's ever been
that's not the problem the problem is
content so what is how do you
differentiate content from story meaning
there's a there's a glut of non-quality
content out there that makes it
difficult to find
the the gems I mean why are we so
disappointed
yeah when we go to the movies these days
yeah the movies are not about it yeah
so real storytelling is in the long form
where you can create so much dimension
in these characters and allow a story to
breathe and be told in the tempo that
the story
um wants to be told with that space and
it's been remarkable and like you know I
was thinking about like how this has
come to be obviously
you know there's there's technology
reasons with streaming
um and and you know there's been an
increasing openness on behalf of
networks and Studios to you know explore
this I mean the BBC was doing this for a
long time before it was happening in
America I've have writers uh that I've
worked with who um who write for HBO for
example
and back when HBO was just beginning and
developing becoming what it is you know
um
the the people at HBO realize that they
they that Network television had
captured the family
and so in order to uh create an audience
for HBO they had to be
anti-family hmm
and so I have friends would go in there
and Pitch stories at HBO and the note
they would get over and over again is
not dark enough
now if you really want to get a writer
excited give them that not dark enough
do you really mean that yes and they did
and out came
you know the the the long form really
developed
um
uh first in in HBO's um uh uh setting
the standard
the reason that long-form television is
become
what it has I think it's the future
and I think um I think that this Century
will see magnificent storytelling
and that these long-form Works will be
the the cathedrals of the 21st Century
and the reason that they are
uh so it's wonderful so often
uh there's a lot of crap too but still
you know what
what does the audience want what does a
reader want
keeps them turning a page what keeps
them coming back episode after episode
what sustains you know some some the
long form series are 100 hours
50 well you know is normal
um two things
revelation
and change
and so they're fascinated with what we
just uh
let's watch some wonderful uh uh series
lately uh peaky blinders that's
fantastic finally got around to it and
it was just great
um you you watch this to see
um who these people really are
and so you see their surface and
there'll be outer behaviors and then
episode after episode you see their
dimensions and a dimension is a
contradiction
in a consistent contradiction in a
character so in one one in one
relationship
um he's really kind in another he's
incredibly cruel and so he's both he's
capable of being being both loving and
gentle and vicious and kind right
depending right
does Smart clever things and makes
terrible mistakes and does stupid thing
whatever and so those contradictions uh
create dimensions and as you're watching
the series you see that these in long
form these are not three-dimensional
characters
uh these are 10 12 15 dimensional
characters literally and if you sit
there and study the character and you
break break down every single Dimension
within them over 50 hours and you see
the three-dimensional characters a
three-dimensional character is a
supporting role yeah so they people want
to see that Revelation because who is
this person and so the complexity of
characters
demands long-form demands complex
characters because you need to reveal
who they really are over years uh to
keep the interest and change
is this character going to Arc from
where they started to where they end and
if if they you know and so we want them
we want to see how and why people change
long form in order to sustain years of
Series has to have extremely complex
characters
multi-dimensional of the extreme kind
and capable of change
and that's why they're and that's so
that is so sad sure it's it it operates
like a Russian novel you know in the
classic sense well I I've looked at
certain novels Russian and otherwise and
I've said if if this was a series
what would cry you know the uh War and
Peace
warm peace if it were a series would be
season one
and that's all
one piece is just six or eight principal
characters
family relationships and love
relationships played out against the
background of Europe and in turmoil it's
more please yeah yeah yeah but it's only
got enough material for 112 episode
season
and it's even the most
a huge thousand page novels
um would be consumed inside of a
long-form series right it it appears to
me that things started to change the the
first real Network show that that kind
of broke the mold uh of of what episodic
television could be to my mind was lost
because it was telling a longer story it
took big swings it didn't always follow
through or connect properly on some of
those swings but it was taking risks and
it was telling a longer story and
because it was successful it was
signaling to the networks and the
studios oh that this could work and then
that you know is is sort of matured in
the cable Universe with The Sopranos and
Breaking Bad and The Wire David Chase
and Vince Gilligan who are telling these
long stories who who understood on some
level like that there was this
um broader Arc and that these characters
were going to land in a very different
place from where they began but with
that also came the the Advent of the
anti-hero as the protagonist right which
is different from Lost and has become
a staple of you know serious
dramatic long-form storytelling so you
know why do you think like why have we
embraced the anti-hero why has you know
the bad guy taken a more Center and I'm
and I'm saying I don't mean that in a in
a perfunctory way I realize there's
multi-dimensions to all of these
characters but in a sense you know it is
a different type of character that all
of us as audience members have really
gravitated towards and connected with
which feels different than prior decades
what it the length helps
and the and the size of the cast also
helps uh because
where are you where an audience places
their empathy
is in relationship to everything that's
around it
and so when an audience or a reader
enters a novel or
film or TV series whatever
instinctively they go in search of the
center of good
they want some positive glow some
positive quality in in them in a major
character
that causes them to think the thought ah
like me
she's like me he's like me okay
and that that positive glow at the
center is in re is in relationship to
everything that's around it
so like in The Sopranos if you surround
Tony with with
um
Mobsters the FBI who's lying and
cheating and whatnot if you surround him
with a darker darker world
and you see that he's troubled
that he has panic attacks
and and he's terrified of something he
doesn't understand the audience goes on
a panic attack just like me
these things I have these moments I have
that he's he's vulnerable
he's a gangster but he's vulnerable just
like me and so he becomes the center of
good
right because it's because your empathy
has to go somewhere
right and generally these anti-heroes
are living by a certain code and that
might not be the code that we would
choose for our own lives but they have
rules codes of code yeah and you know
often it's you know family first or
whatever it is yep and it's very
important that they not violate that
code and within the strictures of that
code there is a certain goodness that
you can identify or a Humanity yeah and
and then and somebody who has um some
code you should say there's something
that that they uh that they would risk
their life for
uh there's some standard that they they
would hold even if it's uh you know long
before uh Tony Soprano there was The
Godfather
and we're used to empathizing with
gangsters in that sense I mean right uh
Ali was done that for for decades and
um uh and so you paint a darker World
you'd turn on a light in the middle of
it and and there's some some positive
quality like I have first a private coat
and we go yeah just like just like me I
too have a code and so they they um they
empathize uh with um with some some
uh some really difficult complex uh
troubling uh characters
I think that's
a huge that's a huge part of it is that
they the writing is so good they know
how to sculpt the the positive and
negative charges
uh in a in a cast and create this glow
at the middle of this
that's one thing
but I also think since the 70s
80s
um
Society in general
slowly waking up uh to what a corrupt
world where we live in
and um
I remember the first big surprise uh
film for that for me for that was uh
Chinatown mm-hmm
and
um and uh uh so I think that the the
writers the writers of who are creating
these great series like the wire and
six feet under you know it was a great
series a Boardwalk Empire right
um
were actually 10 years behind Society
people always ask you know the do
writers lead society and do they create
things that people then emulate whatever
um or to um the society
um does it happen first in society and
the writers are attuned to that and
that's that from is my point of view it
happens first in society because the the
forces of society are so Titanic
um that that culture and and the
economics and the politics of things uh
are um uh
too huge to be led anywhere
and so writers I think are people who
are very sensitive to what's happening
in the world
and
and so when they when they start showing
the dark side people responded
positively to it because they already
knew it was there
and then goes yes that's life that's
that's who we are now that's our you
know whatever and um
uh and and that even to to this day or
that that audience that is willing to
admit what a corrupt World it really is
is is limited
prophets Walk Among Us as a writer and
podcaster for nearly 10 years I've
become more convinced than ever that our
world is populated by scores of
beautiful and brilliant people who have
amazing stories to share those that we
don't know who can teach us something
new and leave us all the better for the
experience of their sharing and so I've
dedicated my career to tracking down the
most compelling profits on the planet
going deep with each of them on my
podcast to elucidate the best of what
they have to offer and to sharing the
insights gleaned for the benefit of all
the podcast is not the only medium by
which to share their stories which is
why I'm proud to announce the release of
my new book voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration and Timeless wisdom that
transpires each week on the ritual
podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
Exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying Standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday profits and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained
with that
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
so here we are now uh in an era in which
you know basically
the anti-hero reign supreme and
culturally and I was talking to Steve
the other day chatting with him about
like what we might talk about and and
one of the things that he brought up
that I was I think is super interesting
and it and it's you know a big part in
in the new book action is you know is
about the Ascension of of the
quote-unquote For Better or Worse like
the bad guy and we're in this kind of
bad guy era in many ways you know Trump
is sort of a classic villain and the
narratives that we see being spun in
popular culture and in politics are you
know about what Trump is doing and we
have Putin and all of these kind of you
know they're they're like Titanic bad
guys right and well and then certain
ways like how is that reflected in in
the the writing presented the American
public thinks that that
Trump descended from heaven and he's
here to lead us so what is going on the
other 70 are not so but there's 30
percent of Americans who really believe
that he is the hero not Mandy here yes
and so
but yeah the majority of people um
to some degree see it for what it is
um when Trump was elected
I know Michael Moore was saying before
the election he's going to get elected
he was calling it very early right and
and he's we're both from Michigan and so
is Michael Moore right yep and uh uh and
I've always known this since I was a kid
growing up in the in the suburbs of
Detroit
uh
I made sure it was the same everywhere
in America but as as kids we thought
that abusive alcoholic fathers was
normal
but nobody ever said that nobody ever
everybody everybody
worshiped the family businesses right
but in the subtext we all knew that that
the worst time of your life is your
childhood
but we denied it and denied it and
denied it that society that America is
the wonderful country that the you know
we just and we just couldn't face it
but now
uh it's out there to be seen and it's so
clear and so I think um uh
storytelling and has responded to
society's
sense that um that we are not who we
pretend to be
and
um and I don't know why we ever thought
we were I mean you know I mean I
living here in um L.A back back when
I used to play golf with some engineers
who were working to take the this
military
system of communication
into the world that became the internet
right right
and they were all excited about what
they're doing
and they they would talk about it
constantly over lunch and whatnot right
and it was fascinating
and they
they at one point they asked me you know
what do you think what do you think of
this I said it's fascinating and if
what you guys are proposing
actually comes true
it will be a perfect mirror of human
nature
and they all smiled
because these Engineers had no idea what
human nature is
and the internet and social media are a
perfect mirror the pornography the
cruelty the meanness of all kinds crime
of all kinds it and and they're able to
do it anonymously
and so the internet has exposed human
nature for what it really is
and they can get away with it for the
most part because it's Anonymous
um and you see how what you know what
here we are sorry creatures we really
are here we are and you know and that my
feeling is that that's got to be a good
thing
because the truth is coming out
little by little
but the truth is coming out
and and people are going to have to live
in a reality that they would that they
denied throughout history for the most
part right so you're saying basically
that gives us a chance the opportunity
to actually reckon with it and perhaps
uh you know transcend it hopefully it's
a macro version of yeah the being in
denial of the alcoholic's father right
exactly you just have to stop pretending
right this is who we are and living in
reality is in a Freud Freud once said
he's
uh he said uh it's impossible to live in
reality
he said just try it try for one minute
to live in absolute
brutal Rock Bottom reality for one full
minute and he said within 20 seconds
you'll start to fantasize
he says it's just too awful the mind
can't bear it right
and this is why we write stories
well what is reality how do you define
reality we're all uh you know operating
through the lens of our perception and
our perception you know creates the the
epistemics the heuristics uh you know by
you know by how we make sense of the
world right and story really is the core
functioning operating system for all of
that like story is uniquely human it's
what makes us who we are and uh you know
gives us this framework right so let's
go back to just defining what story is
and and you know it's just it's curious
to me that you know story and Humanity
cannot be you know they're inextricably
linked with each other we're the we're
the one creature on earth that is really
operating on story all the time and
stories are functioning in very visible
ways but also in so many invisible ways
and and all of that really dictates
the decisions that we make and and you
know how we kind of function in the
world
when you take an action in life at any
moment
you take an a you know you uh you always
take an action designed to create a
positive reaction
that will help you get toward what you
want
right I mean this is as old as Socrates
is that all human beings act toward the
good for their perception of the good
the worse the people act toward what
they perceive to be
The Good the positive I mean when it
when somebody gets on a school bus with
a uh jacket uh
dynamite and blows up uh uh himself and
all the kids on that bus that person
believes he's doing God's work
okay so all human beings act toward the
positive so you always take an action
you certainly do to create a reaction
which will somehow help you toward what
you want
even if what you want is to make
somebody else feel bad okay so you
insult people because it's satisfying to
watch them suffer from one right or you
compliment them because you want them to
whatever right
um
how do you know what to do in order to
cause a reaction that will get you a
step toward what you want
if you only had your living experience
you would know what to do
you'd be paralyzed you wouldn't know
what to do
and so how do you know what actions to
take in life to get what you want
because you have been told stories since
you're a child you have read stories as
a child you have seen them countless on
by the tens of thousands of stories from
everything from from TV commercials to
you know crime and punishment
uh that whole stockpile of of story
is buried in your memory and gives you
a sense
of if I do this in these circumstances
that person will
take an action that will help you
whatever
um because life without story life is um
uh would be terrifying unlim there's
also something you wouldn't know what to
do right it's it's giving you this
framework
um
but I think there's also something
uh unique about story in that it tends
to like a story well told Will
live rent free in your conscious or
unconscious mind in perpetuity right
like what is it about a great story well
told that can that can just
um impact us so profoundly as opposed to
the imparting of the information like
you can say to somebody and this is kind
of like you know what I do here on the
podcast like some people will they're an
expert in something and they'll come in
and they'll say here are the five things
you should be doing every day or
something like that and you could take
that information and some people might
even act on that but that's very
different from somebody who comes in and
tells an incredible story in which those
tenets or principals are are conveyed
that will live with that person and have
a much more profound effect and also uh
more likely to actually get them to
change their behavior than a listicle or
some bullet points or a PowerPoint or
what have you so you know from that
you know I'm always trying to like you
know default to storytelling over just
the information
um
and uh
and I can't help but like Wonder like
why is that like what is good like how
did we evolve to learn in that way is
such that in a neuroscientists have um
been looking at this um for at least 40
or 50 years now
and what they've come to understand is
that the mind is a story making machine
the mind takes its experience at every
moment and is narratizing everything
that happens to it
and so it's it's understanding of
reality is based upon the stories that
it has told itself
and that that that
it's a it's why we human beings are able
to you know to Rule the World As We as
we do is because we and we can take raw
experience and
do first of all be look into the subtext
and ask the question why
why did that just happen
and your mind penetrates that and says
it recognizes there must have been a
force in there there must have been a
need she wanted this he wanted that this
this business wants that the government
wants that there's these desires going
in inside and that and they're they're
motivating these behaviors and these
forces are hidden underneath and then
they they manifest themselves in a
behavior but if you track back to it you
discover the reasons why no other no
animal ever asks why only human beings
ask why right and then human beings like
that little Annoying five-year-old who
says why daddy why why why why why why
why
the major question out of the mouth of
kids is why they want to understand
causality
they want to understand how one thing
causes another how that effect then
becomes a cause it causes triggers
another effect and they want to
understand the interconnectedness of
life
they want us to understand why
stories Express why
at the end of a story you understand if
it's well told why these characters
these metaphors for human beings did
what they did
what they wanted why they wanted it how
they went about trying to get it and so
the story educates you on the hows and
whys of things perhaps most profound of
of the stories uh that impact Our Lives
For Better or Worse are the stories that
we tell ourselves about ourselves we're
all walking around with some version of
a locked in narrative right that either
liberates us or imprisons US probably
imprisons us you know and probably is
working in disservice
known as self-deception okay yeah none
of these stories are true whether
they're good or bad they're all their
illusions that true in the sense they're
not they're not factual yeah they may
have a real truth in boom however about
why we did what we did but
yes trying to make sense out of our own
life and we go back
and uh with regret often mm-hmm
why did I do that
why didn't that work why did I fail at
that or why would or or was I just lucky
I mean we're trying to make sense out of
our own life and so we we we tell
ourselves stories
yeah out of our memories and these these
the stories that we tell ourselves are
very selective yeah and deceptive so
what's the story that that you tell
yourself about yourself you know some
years ago um I was lecturing in um Spain
and um
a journalist there
asked me a question nobody had ever
asked me which was because I'd probably
by by this time I'd been lecturing for
at least you know 25 years and uh
and he asked me why
is why do you do this why do you travel
you know you you must have made enough
money by now why why do you keep
traveling the world
and trying to help people compose
insightful honest
stories uh
uh first page stage and Screen why why
do you do this
and I had to think because I had never
until he asked me that question I had
never really
thought to ask myself that
and uh
I said well
um
very little in life very little
is Meaningful
it's random it's far far more random
than we want to believe
but meaning is a function of of choice
you can attribute meaning meaning is
something that we give to something else
yeah it's it's as what I was saying was
there's no there is no intrinsic meaning
to life
it is a biological accident that
occurred on this planet maybe others but
there is no intrinsic meaning that
doesn't mean it's not the same thing as
saying life is meaningless
because it there is no intrinsic meaning
but you as the existentialist used to
teach you have to find your project you
have to find out what gets you up in the
morning
what's your purpose in life you have to
you have to give your life meaning
and you have to do it yourself if you
wait for other people to do it and you
know you will leave you will live an
invalid life it won't be your life
you'll be leading other people's lives
and so I I thought you know I said
there's no intrinsic meaning uh
and so what is my meaning why do I do
this
and the answer that I gave him uh
was this
the no there is there is no intrinsic
meaning
in reality in life
there is however suffering
that's real
human beings suffer
all living things suffer
that's what it is to be alive is to
suffer
anything that a person can do
to alleviate the suffering in others
is a good thing a positive thing a
meaningful thing
stories do exactly that they make life
livable
they Elite they help
alleviate the suffering because great
great suffering comes from confusion
from just not understanding things I
don't know why I don't know why why is
this happening to me who am I Etc
there are terrifying things and and you
suffer in that confusion
right so it's providing this map of
meaning that
is giving you an explanation or a better
understanding for your own personal
struggles but also making it a shared
experience like if you're relating to
somebody else who's gone through
something analogous you don't feel quite
alone or that your experience is unique
from your fellow man yeah is that a
question of um stories don't tell us
what we should do
uh it's a difference between
ought and is
we ought to do things but we have ideals
we understand you know we have certain
standards that we want to achieve we
have ideals and we ought to live up to
our moral ideals our artistic ideals
right we ought to but then there's is
what is
and
um
stories great stories make what is clear
they don't tell you what you ought to do
you know
um uh Lord of the Flies
there's a magnificent novel about human
nature but it doesn't tell you what you
ought to do it just says this is human
nature this is what it is right right
right and the more you understand what
is
the less suffering you go through
because you you you you're living in in
reality you're living in the is rather
than the ought
you can still have your ideals and
aspirations as long as they're not you
know
full of Hope right well extrapolating on
that idea of of you know suffering as as
being fundamental and you know a a
primary aspect of of The Human Condition
I've heard you speak many times about uh
you know the idea of life being a
struggle right you bristle at this
notion that describe Life as a journey
and I want to kind of understand this a
little bit better and perhaps you know
you can indulge me in pushing back a
little bit
um
so let's let's deconstruct that a little
bit that's it a journey is a California
word and there you know there are many
share you know you you just can't tell
anybody anything in California you must
share it with them well here we are in
California yes and we're gonna we're
gonna share some ideas on this I mean
the way I look at it is
you know Journey the word Journey itself
is a very broad word it's it's also
somewhat neutral whereas yeah it's not
struggle even it should be it should be
you're right it should be journey is it
can be negative or positive right it
doesn't exist on an extreme of the
polarities
if you want to Define it that way but
that's not how people use it they they
use it as something else as a euphemism
euphemisms are words to protect us from
reality we don't call it [__] we call it
number two okay
you follow we use euphemisms because we
can't face reality it's too ugly it's
too awful it's what it is and uh it's
painful and uh and so we uh we wanna we
wanna um live in a uh you know like I
said denial as as
psychologists have pointed out
since forever denial makes the world go
round and
journey is a word that makes it possible
to deny the truth
if you say life is a journey
a journey is you get on a bus in
Cleveland
and it takes you to Chicago and you sit
there watching the countryside go by
that's a journey
life is not like that it's a struggle
and Uphill it's Sisyphus in that rock
yeah but it's also all the beautiful
colors of the rainbow like here's my
point
I know let me just finish this thought
so I do think journey is a broader term
that you know struggle is very
connotative and and and and somewhat
reductive in a negative sense like
struggle of course is part of the
journey it's an essential part of it but
doesn't the word Journey also make room
for the spectrum of of experiences from
Joy To Love and celebration and
heartbreak and setbacks and conflict
it's all of it right like that the
journey is how people use the word okay
they use it to avoid I I get your
realization that it's a [__] it's not
easy it's hard people are
terrible much of the time you have to
deal with people you know I mean one of
the best things to come out of the
pandemic is people are now working at
home and they're so pleased to be
working at home why because they don't
have to be around other people
[Laughter]
is that
right and so yeah I know I know but
look I teach writers
it's very important
from my point of view that writers use a
truthful precise language
that they do not indulge in euphemisms
because if they use euphemisms
in their own mind how can they possibly
interpret reality in an honest uh
truthful way and celebrate it when it
needs celebration a lamented when it
doesn't right but but if if writers use
words to separate themselves from
reality how in the world could they ever
write anything that would bring the
audience or the reader into contact with
reality
and so that's why I get you know I get
you know
peevish I know it's boring no it's not
boring I love it I mean there's a it's
it's not idle I mean there's a re I
um
I don't like the word hope
much
hope
is the denial of reality
if you really think about the
possibility of me achieving what I want
to achieve what
what are the odds I mean is it possible
you could get what you want
but the chances are you won't
or it's also the engine of tackling and
and overcoming obstacles right you can't
face uh you know
dire or tragic circumstances without
some you can't get into action without
some sliver of hope that you'll be able
to navigate it and get to the other the
difference between expectation and hope
I mean there are anticipation and hope
and that that's just because if people
use the word hope in the same way that
they use the word uh uh
anticipation
or expectation
I'd be fine sure right so when people
when people are are going through hell
and somebody says well there's always
hope right no I I understand that you
know that's that's green card [__]
yeah right I understand what you're
saying I mean fundamentally what you're
getting at is honesty right like how can
we strip away artifice and really you
know pull pull the covers on on reality
and you know use writing as a and story
as a means of elucidating The Human
Condition in in its truth right and
that's the core of great writing
whatever story it is you're trying to
tell see if if if if a writer is going
to fault
one way or another
I would rather that they fall toward
cynicism
certainly skepticism
then fault toward optimism hope and
everything's going to turn out all right
happy endings
right I mean it's not that you you can't
have a positive ending if the characters
earn it you have to earn it yeah that's
the difference
um
but I but again you know again the the
the
happy endings
uh
uh is is a is a commercial imperative
yeah well it just you know any audience
member knows whether they're conscious
of it or not uh the difference between a
happy ending earned and one that's
saccharin and you know kind of slapped
on top yeah and you leave like maybe
did you um watch the series leftovers oh
I I made a list because I wanted to talk
about my favorite long form yeah uh
shows and that's up at the top like I I
just think and that ending it's one of
the greatest it's one of the most yeah
powerful beautiful endings of anything
I've ever experienced in my life and
those characters have earned that love
in that moment
um and so it's a positive ending but it
isn't a happy ending in the
Hollywood sense of the word it is a
positive ending they've reached
something worthy in their lives
something of of real quality in their
lives but they've been through hell to
get there
and
and it's it's an honest ending
positive and honest yeah
um and so um and so I'm not against
Happy Endings I'm just against the
sentimentation who who out there is is
really killing it like who in your mind
is is is is is is really doing the great
work right now what have you enjoyed or
consumed recently that you think really
rises above
um
did ah
I mentioned peaky blinders I just
finished that and I thought that was
wonderful that but that's from like five
years ago right well I think the recent
the most recent season was recently this
yeah that's true that's true I you know
when people ask that question I I uh
um
who knows that you know I
a series
that has stuck with me
for the last year or two or whatever
um and it's called made
I don't think I've seen that m-a-i-d
made
and I just loved it
and
um it did okay got some nominations and
so forth
um it's about a a single mom
and her uh her
empty yet aren't they ever actually
married I don't think they were but they
were you know living together
um is an alcoholic and abusive and and
she takes her kid and she has she's
never had a job
she has almost no education
and she's thrown into the world
and she gets a job cleaning houses
and over the course of the series
grows as a human being
just figures out how things work how she
works what's her what her real values
are she's got a crazy mother and
otherwise but
um until and finally she gets herself
um
uh to college
positive
happy ending but she really earned it
and
um and why does that serious you know
pop to mind when you ask that question I
can only say that it's I think it's
wonderfully done
um as usual beautifully acted but that's
that's everything now I mean they act
the actors as a community of artists
are 10 years ahead of the writers
every time you turn on TBC you see these
wonderful performances and you say where
are they where they come
um
but I think the reason it it got me is
that that's a world I don't know single
mom
cleaning houses
um and the the writing was so terrific
Ernest writing
um
um there's some scenes in there that
deal with Hoarders
I've I've known one hoarder in my life a
mother-in-law had some time ago
um
and um they decide then some order
decides to clean up their house but they
can't do it themselves
I mean they're not yeah emotionally able
right so they get a cleaning company and
um uh
uh or or or a house is um going to be
put up for sale
and so the realtor brings in a cleaning
company to make that house Sparkle for
the buyers and the cleaners see what
the previous owners
how they lived
and how they left it
I mean there was insights there into uh
lower middle class middle class lower
class uh from an angle Through The Eyes
of people who have to clean up the mess
that people leave
and at the same time she's growing as a
character and evolving uh based on a
true story based on the factuals
um
I'd never seen anything I've never
experienced anything like that and so I
thought it was terrific and um you know
nobody knows it yeah I know I thought
I'd seen all the great long forms out
there well it's not that long I mean
it's one season you know it's like eight
episodes all right
um I I always hesitate over that that
question because
um
I
you get judged by your answer so if I if
I like um you know the Norseman
yeah okay
well Mayhem right
uh uh people say yeah you know that's
these yeah right you're gonna get yeah I
get it I mean I like the maid too you
know there's but I also like the
Norseman so uh so uh uh it's the choices
are wonderful today
uh I mean the the good fight is coming
back
um and my judgment the greatest TV
series uh uh a ball is Better Call Saul
hmm
uh Breaking Bad All Time more than
Sopranos more than Breaking Bad Man all
the time wow okay no
now I say better call Saul's greatest TV
series never Rich okay and then somebody
turns on episode one and my
recommendation and they find this crazy
Jimmy Mcgill and his uh uh
mean-spirited brother and all the rest
of it
um and just force them to death right
and they're going to say well who who is
this expert Mickey what the hell is you
know I'm you know so I'm just I just say
look
um
explore
and get Netflix and HBO and and Prime
and you know the usual who who learn all
The Usual Suspects and uh and go looking
um and when you when you
something captures you
and if it really works for you uh you're
going to have um uh a quality of
experience a depth and breadth of
experience in long-form television that
no human beings ever had prior to the
21st century yeah
yeah it's a beautiful thing this is this
is what what
we're creating now is breathtaking and
um uh unlike it surpasses in in its
density and it's in its complexity and
uh Powers
um
um much of everything that we've ever I
mean there's still Shakespeare in this
sure sure I mean it's yeah it's where
all the talent and the great work is
happening right now right now we are
very fortunate to live in a world where
the the quality of um and the insights
into character
insights into society what's right and
wrong with our society
um are really astute and um
I I I can't keep up with it yeah there's
too much it's too much all the foreign
language stuff too there's amazing
foreign yes if you start looking if you
if you you know if you're willing to
read subtitles and you see all the stuff
that's coming out of Denmark and Sweden
and uh Oregon libero from France was
unbelievable yeah but anyway let's let's
shift gears here a little bit I mean
when you
you know with all of the amazing writers
that you've mentored and worked with
over the years I mean
to your mind what distinguishes
good from the greats like when you think
of William Goldman who was a student of
yours and as a friend of yours like what
makes him that much better than someone
you know just 10 percent less successful
like what is the edge that makes the
great people great it's talented and
what is that how does that translate
what are they doing me I cannot I you
know I teach what I teach people take it
and use it as they will and the fact
that certain students of mine are really
um the highest uh water uh
um is um is a question of talent and
I mean to unders you know you can Define
talent it's really simple
um a talent creative Talent is the
discovery of the third thing
a talented person over on the right side
of their brain
um they have a faculty
you know a creative IQ you're
conventional IQ is over on your left
side this is you know simplistic but
yeah
um uh but the creative IQ is certain
people have the power to discover
the hidden connection
between two things that already exist
but a third thing that connects them
in a way no one else has ever thought
before so what would be an example
analogical logic uh example I often give
in class is that little poem that you
read in junior high school I think it is
it's called the fog
Carl sandburg's the fog
and there's a phrase in there well this
is the fog
uh rolled in another fog
I think it's moved I forgot
but the fog moved in on little cat's
feet
fog is weather
cat's feet
is an animal
there is no necessary relationship
between them
but Sandberg found a relationship
between fog and Cat's feet and when he
puts it together in that in that in that
simile like
uh cat's feet
um a third thing is Born Into the world
which is the relationship between fog
and Cat's feet
that's creativity it's analogical logic
it's the discovery of the Hidden
connection
it's a it's a delusional to think that
you create from nothing
you cannot make something out of nothing
what artists do is they take what is
and they find connections between all of
what is
and they fuse them into third things
that are wonderful or beautiful and
enriched somehow when they do it really
well right and that with the the kind of
hidden piece there also is that it has
to be true right like that idea of the
fog and the cat's feet when you yeah
contemplate if there was an app it not
only elevates like the the visceral
experience of that you know it innately
like oh yeah that is what it is
absolutely and that's we know one uh
we're not you know when they when
someone's writing
and they're reaching for uh a metaphor
uh or they or a metaphor comes to mind
and they try it out and they go no
that's
yeah that's not right
so they look for another one another one
you know different right and and out of
ten they might find one that is really
fresh
and true
and that's the one they use and so it's
not as if these these uh tropes of
languages but fall out of the brain they
most of what falls out of the brain is
worthless so you have to have taste and
judgment as to know what's so how do you
think about how do you think about the
idea of the Muse though like the Unseen
you know inspiration and the the the
mystical art of you know drawing down
upon imagination Steve pressfield
I might find the tension in your uh you
know perspectives here he wrote that
wonderful book The War of Art and I
wrote the preface to it and um
his publisher asked me to write the
preface to it and um and I said I think
it's a wonderful book it's a beautiful
book but I I can't buy the muse
and and his publisher said good because
neither do I
it's I said but there is
Talent
and it is subconscious
and so it seems as if it's coming from
outside of you
descending from above whatever metaphor
you want to use right but of course it's
coming from you it's you you're doing
this nobody else and if it's a mystery
to you it's because it's subconscious
and
uh but you know as well as anyone that
that many a great artists will say I
didn't create this thing it kind of came
through me like there's this idea of
being you know well first of all you
have to understand receiving artists you
have to understand I
think the marketing of artists okay
right
they want to appear mysterious
we all know anybody who worked knows
that that if you keep 10 of what you
write it's remarkable
more likely something like five or two
or whatever it's a tiny tiny percentage
of what comes through you that you
actually keep
right uh and and and so they know that
you know when look what is it what is it
to write what is it actually like it's
it's such an awesome terrible you sit
down a piece of paper okay
or screen on your computer
and um
he says she says and you knock out a
scene
takes Maybe
10 minutes
then what do you do you read what you've
written
and as you read it you critique it oh
that's terrible aren't even nice you and
the humans in there whatever right and
and then you you go back and and you
rewrite it
and then what do you do you read it
again
and what in your service what what what
works what doesn't and mostly it still
doesn't work maybe one or two things you
keep
and you and then you go back and you
rewrite and if you if you have a
stopwatch at your
uh keypad the way um uh the way uh
lawyers do
and kept track of how much time do I
spend actually writing a scene and how
much time do I spend critiquing it
and playing with it and then rewriting
it the time you spend critiquing and
analyzing is ten times the time you
spent writing probably more than that
and probably much more than that
I mean you know we've all you know
written one paragraph a day
right and and to come to sit down the
next morning and go a piece of [__] and
out that whole paragraph that you spent
a whole day on it's gone
uh
foreign
but if if you tell people that
if the writer said you have no idea how
hard it is man
I spend you know
maybe in a 20 minutes a day creating
something that that you know that I then
spend the next 10 hours savaging and I
often just throw the whole thing out and
start all over again it's really hard
work it's Gotti you know it drives you
crazy and you're not you're you're
you're you're your guts are in a knot
all day long and that's why we drink
right right if you actually said that to
people okay
nobody wants to hear that what they want
to believe is that they were walking
down the street and they just descended
out of The Ether and me and through me
and it you know I get that I mean
there's a Workman like wood shedding of
you know that that dispels the romance
and the you know mysticism of the whole
thing and the vast majority of writing
is painful and hard and you know it's
boring yeah and boring right and lonely
and all of that all the rest but there
are those moments of inspiration or
temporary flow States where there's a
sense of uh of ease about it right of
course and you'd celebrate those and you
go you know at the end of the day if
you've got a decent
pass at whatever page that you're
working on and you read it you go that's
not bad you know that's a good day yeah
um
no I it's it's
I lectured I teach and I write for
writers and it if anybody has to be
honest about it I do yeah
I can't I can't in I can't invite people
into this world
look
somebody decides I'm going to be you
know get out of college you're going to
be a writer
they have to be willing to fail for the
next 10 years
that's 10
Major Works 10 novels 10 films 10 plays
10 of whatever at least one a year at
least one a year
and for the next 10 years and nobody
wants them
that's real right
[Music]
and I cannot pretend to uh my students
that that you're going to have success
by just following this through that one
thing or another and um and you know
it'll flow it'll just come down to you
or whatever right no I get it and I
think you know that's a big piece in the
success of of the seminars is the fact
that you tell it like it is like this is
the truth of the matter this is a very
difficult Road I'm actually restrained
are you well that's that's a good segue
in time I'm actually restrained if I
wanted listen you I'm finding you to be
very gentlemanly here and and and and
reserved and you know that conjures the
the scene and adaptation which you know
upon seeing that made me intimidated to
meet you here today uh because that you
know iconic scene sort of precedes you
can we talk about adaptation true of
course I mean first of all one of my
all-time favorite movies and and and
that sequence and you're uh you know
your persona being rendered by Brian Cox
so brilliantly in that movie
um
just you know lives with me it's
incredible right and I know there's a
great back story here can you tell that
story uh
uh why Brian Cox is that the well just
you know how did this whole thing yeah
oh God I know you've told it yeah yeah I
um
um phone rang one day
and it was a producer calling from New
York uh Ed Saxon
and um he said we uh we have a problem
and I thought they wanted me to script
doctor right so we have a problem so
it's a problem he said well we've got
this writer Charlie Kaufman and he's
he's written a screenplay
and it may and made you a character in
it
he has freely stolen from your lectures
and your book without obviously
permission
um and we don't know what to do well you
know what to do you know he had to call
you and get you on board I said I said
you know send me the script
so I read it and um was that the first
had you did you know Charlie Kaufman
before no no no no no no no no no no he
didn't know what his particular flavor
of right and um and I could see that
what he wanted me to be is the villain
he wanted me to represent Hollywood
right and he perceives Hollywood as the
villain
and and that um and Hollywood is uh
formulaic
and uh and he perceived me as formula an
insult to his creative genius exactly
and um and uh and but I also realized he
needs a villain because otherwise the
screenplay sucks
right otherwise it's just a you know
it's just a
masturbation about how awful it is to be
a writer the stuff we were just talking
about and uh
and
very importantly the third Act
sucked it was awful
um so I called Ed Saxon back and um I
said I see what he's up to
uh and I can you know I see your concern
because
um if you go ahead with this project I
would sue you for everything you've got
hmm
anything you know I said well here's
what we're going to do one
you're going to write a redeeming scene
from my character
two
I have to have say in the casting
and three there has to be a a whole new
third act because the third act sucks
and I can't be a character in a bad
movie
how did it originally end what was the
difference oh uh uh Susan Orleans shoots
a cup
so it didn't have any of the meta nature
of how you know the yeah okay
and and um and that you know
Charlie Kaufman is is a
a fascinating guy in that
and there's many people like him
he's trying for the impossible
he wants to have a commercially
successful art movie
he wants art and money
I respect that though and I would argue
that he succeeded you know he succeeded
I get it I mean some of the not all of
them you know I mean
you know right but he pretends he only
wants to be an artist
in fact he knows how Hollywood Works he
knows if he doesn't make money he won't
he won't he won't be working
and so um and so it's a bit hypocritical
but you know yeah pretentious
um but that's okay I said okay I said
but you know I said so we're gonna have
to have meetings
uh-huh so art imitates life imitates art
yeah like what you're doing in the movie
you're now doing for the movie yeah
well you know before I decided to go for
it Go with It
uh and my conditions
I I talked to two people
I called William Goldman mm-hmm
and I said bill they want to make me a
character in a movie and uh yeah let me
just interject for a moment apologies
but for people that don't know arguably
the greatest screenwriter of all time
wrote which cut Cassidy All the
President's Men Marathon Man yeah
go ahead certainly the greatest writer
of dialogue sure in the history of the
movies and um and he said don't do it
I said well and they're gonna they think
they're gonna give me permission on the
casting he's already
right yeah okay who do you want
I said uh Gene Hackman he's okay it'll
be Gene Hackman with a big pink bow
around his neck
he said Bob they're out to get you
yeah no matter how you slice it you're
gonna end they're gonna get you if you
let them they're gonna get you don't do
it
so then I called my son
I said Paul and he said do it
I said but William Goldman says you know
he's a dad
you're going to be a character in a
Hollywood film you in fact I'd already
been a character in one film called 20
dates this is going to be another
character now I've been in a major
Hollywood film
he said no matter what you know you know
do it you'll love it do it and uh
so then I called uh Saxon back and I
said um you know I have to have cash
whatever and uh we and uh we have to
have a writer's meetings with me in them
and um we've got to find the third act
that that
and the third act that they came up with
I said okay
but I knew
um only half the audience would go with
it
when it pivots towards his brother's
version of what a good story is lifted
from what he learned in your seminar
basically right and then I thought it
was fantastic well yeah but I think it's
one of the great products well but I
mean it's certainly yeah you can unlike
anything when
um
I tell you whether the where the the
dividing line comes and in that moment
that Meryl Streep's character Susan
Orleans says we're going to have to kill
him right that's the Rubicon where it
all changes half the audience went on
and they just didn't believe anything
after that
but they're missing it I know I know I
agree I agree with you uh it just
becomes so absurd
yeah and
um
what you know what what was that like
working with Spike and Charlie oh they
were great they were great they're
they're very they were great and um
they they didn't argue
because I
but that was it was their idea to make
that pivot and you just help them craft
that so that it would they they wanted
the they
wanted the ending they first sent me and
I said no that's out and and but I sat
down and I explained to them why
and and they're reasonable people and
they sat there and oh yeah I suppose
yeah yeah and and and then and then and
they said or
you can do it without me
and if you you know if you if it becomes
a page one if you put me in the if if
you if if if I have if I if I do not
approve the last Act
and you put me in that then you will be
faced with a lawsuit and and uh that I
will win and uh uh and uh so they tried
to do it without my character uh-huh
and I and I they sent me that draft
without my character in it and it really
sucked
so then they came back and they said
yeah well you know you we have to have
you in the in the movie and uh I said
well then my conditions stand they need
to find a third act that works and so I
sat down with them and I gave notes and
they never they didn't argue they're
very not put you know cut plate and
listening and I didn't tell him what to
write
I said this is why this doesn't work and
this doesn't work that doesn't work
whatever and
um and uh I see what you're trying to do
but you haven't gotten there yet yeah
yeah so anyway it read about it all at
the end of the day it always you know
right of course and and Brian Cox was
your casting choice
well yeah what happened was um uh I said
um
I can't tell you who you must cast
because who knows whether that actor is
available
I said
um but I want you to give me a list
and um uh what I needed to know was
their casting philosophy
for all I knew
they saw the the for the McKee character
this could be the Dan Aykroyd Danny
DeVito School of sarcastic right
and so I said send me a list and it was
the top 10 British actors of the day
so you were on the same page tonally
I had no I I didn't I've never imagined
myself as Michael Caine
but you need that that gravaman well I I
saw what they were after I saw what
they're after and
um Brian Cox's name was not on the list
and I said okay I see what you're after
okay uh I would like you to audition
Brian Cox and they said who's Brian Cox
and I said he's the best British actor
you don't know yeah
and so they went to London and they and
Dorchester
can come in the suite and they within
two minutes they knew it that you know
it was perfect and why Brian Cox over
Michael Kane I'll tell you actors
wonderful actors
like I mean that on that list was
Christopher Plummer I mean you know it
was incredible
um
when they're playing a
an antagonist
there's always this subtext of
love me love me love me yes I'm a bad
guy yes I do terrible things but my
heart is in the right place little a
little uh break the break the fourth
wall wink
it's how you they don't have to do no
they're too good at that they wouldn't
matter they would that's they wouldn't
wink they would not think they actually
it would be but they're convinced
certain yeah
thing going on a certain
suffering a certain whatever
there would be the love me thing
and as wonderful as those actors are
that for me that would be fatal
I do not want my students to love me
I want them to respect me
I want them to learn from me
but I do not want to be loved
I don't want a bunch of people chasing
me around you know becoming uh you know
my flock I hate that I I I I hate that
you hate the word guru right that gets
yeah because it's an insult to them
it's not only an insult to me
uh you know in the ancient meaning of it
just meant teacher but uh but Guru in
the modern terms is somebody who gets um
uh you know innocent people and to fall
in love with them yeah and becomes a
yeah uh and he milks them for all the
money they can he can get no I don't
know what so yeah I hate the word guru
and
um uh I'd I don't want followers I don't
want that
um so if if people
[Music]
that's a sick relationship you know the
the mentor student thing and that if if
it goes to the point where the student
can't write without the mentor there
approving it or whatever now I mean how
are you going to grow up be a writer
writer is somebody who stands right and
also the the the audiences your seminars
is populated with people who've won
Emmys and Oscars who return and return
and return yeah to remind themselves or
to work through a particular problem
that they're having like these are
highly accomplished
and so the word guru not only insults me
as a person who's preying on people but
it insults them as fools to be preyed on
when in fact there's a tremendous amount
of success and talent sitting in that
room and
most of my most of my students are over
40 years old these are kids
these are Pros yeah and um
so anyway uh so Brian Cox is gonna drive
he's gonna drop the hammer right well
you see it now and you see it now in the
succession yet auger it augered Logan
Roy in many ways I mean there's a lot of
similarities in that portrayal
Brian Cox is a wonderful actor who does
not do that love me thing
and I knew Brian uh I met him up is a
student of mine and came to lecture up
in Glasgow and I knew him from uh his
performances on the stage in the West
End
and um and uh small movies because I
lived in England for 10 years and so
that's how I knew Brian because I'd seen
him repeatedly uh on stage or screen and
it was a student
uh and I I watched him in a a play
called uh uh skylight
David hair play
and um and I really admired
that that
he's not asking for sympathy
and I could imagine another actor
playing that character and woe is me and
missing misunderstood and I really I
mean I could imagine but he didn't and
so anyway that's why Brian yeah iconic I
mean were you happy with how it came out
oh sure you know I I took my son Paul to
a screening
and uh and uh imagine what you know it's
it's one thing for me to see myself
portrayed
but imagine for a son to see his father
and so after uh we went out to the
parking lot and I said so what did you
think
and Paul said dad he nailed you
there you go yeah did you ever uh speak
with Nicholas Cage about it
no I've never met him yeah
you're saying
um I love it I think it's fantastic and
you know I'm a I'm a Charlie Kaufman fan
and a Spike Jones fan and that movie is
a movie I probably revisit you know
every year or so yeah but when you think
about master storytellers and I would
consider both of those guys you know
among that that group often you hear uh
about how they Flex the rules or they're
the ones that are breaking the rules so
it's back to this idea that's you know
you see a theme in adaptation which is
the you know the structure is the bad
guy and the Geniuses are the ones who
are operating outside of it and you know
I think it I want to hear your
perspective on this because there's a
lot of confusion I think around this
when you think about
you know whether it's Tarantino or
Charlie Kaufman they are all operating
within a structure that might elude the
the average viewer but in truth they're
all adhering to you know time tested
tenets of good storytelling sure and um
but that's the the word uh rule
rules and is another word like journey
and
great to see you
there is no such thing in art
there are no rules
there's a form
and the form
has a purpose
it there's a
painting for example
almost virtually all paintings are
rectangular
why
because if they're square or circular
it reduces everything to a symmetry
symmetry has no tension it's boring to
the eye all right and so there's a
there's a form the rectangular frame is
designed to put objects in a certain
lines or colors or whatever you're
working with in certain positions within
that rectangle to create attention and
that that holds the eye moves the eye
right and it's not a rule
nobody says you have to paint in a
rectangular screen for a frame it's a
form it's used for a purpose it creates
tension
and so and so
um
the
the the
people who think that storytelling has
rules and I really you know I react
against that there are no rules there's
a form
you you know that life goes
out of balance
at some point
and that it went out of balance makes us
wonder how and why will these characters
if possible we store the balance of life
and the story then is a struggle toward
achieving that balance positive or
negative or something ironic in between
um and so throwing life out of balance
and the and the the conflicts in the
effort to put it back into balance is
not a rule is is a form if life doesn't
go out of balance
there's no story
it's a portrait right and so you can't
say you have to throw the life out of
balance is a rule
it's just the it's the nature of the art
form
it's the rectangular frame it's you know
the movement from imbalance toward
balance is the rectangular frame of a
story told in time and
um
and
it it and and I try to get uh writers to
to understand that nobody's telling you
how to write there are no rules if you
if you write something that is
absolutely wonderful no matter what and
an intelligent sensitive people read it
your career will be made because it's
absolutely wonderful okay right right
and you have captured something that is
um that is compelling
how you do that there's a form
and it for thousands of years this is
how people telling stories have a shape
to story
uh and there's certain
uh elements that that are uh uh constant
um and uh and uh uh but
you could do it like um uh you know like
like the the the film betrayal you could
tell the story backwards if you want to
betrayal is told backwards
right
and you might remember betrayal I don't
know I'm trying to remember I don't
think I saw that starts with a with a uh
uh uh
the first scene is a couple years after
their affair
uh
where they were married just each
married to somebody else or she was
married
and she says he knows
her husband has just learned about their
Affair her husband is this is that
character's best friend
and then it works its way back and then
you go backwards in time into this the
film ends on Boy Meets Girl hmm
and it works beautifully by it's an
exercise in dramatic irony
at every point we know more than the
characters know
uh and uh
and says you know how well how will
these characters react you know what
what made this how would they react when
they find out what we already know got
it so it's a you can turn it on its head
in my the book I wrote on um character
uh I explored the whole spectrum of
character including radical characters
from avant-garde
uh modernist post-modernist
um plays films and and novels uh and uh
uh uh because that's choice
if you want to you could write like
Samuel Beckett and you you know create
absolutely radical characters
uh and and I'm going to do the same
thing in um in um in the next book on
story is uh I'm going to show them the
Full Spectrum which includes
um absurdist
right on on uh
on the subject of dialogue there are
certain very talented writers who are
super idiosyncratic in the way they
write like I'm thinking of Mamet Sorkin
again with Tarantino dialogue that is
incredibly poetic but also dialogue that
that draws very much draws attention to
itself right like you know a Sorkin
scene like you you know who wrote that
scene yeah
but when you say you you mean us people
in the business I suppose but if you're
a general audience any form of General
audience the general audience would not
know that there's like a trademark
staccato or you know mametisms or the
way the Tarantino writes that the fellow
writers so they are the authors of those
works because much so but because you
don't want to suggest Rick that that
when people go to see something by
Tarantino or or uh Sorkin that the
average person or the watches this is
saying the glass working hmm
uh Tarantino
they're not they're they're into the
story and you don't think so with
Tarantino even yeah even with Tarantino
that's interesting yeah you know they
but then I don't know movie movie fans
are fans uh and uh maybe there is some
of that but the reason I uh call
attention to that
is that I wouldn't want
somebody that I'm teaching thinking that
they should develop an eccentric style
of dialogue that calls attention to
itself that's what I'm I'm getting at
it's one thing if you're a master but
other than that it feels like artifice
and distraction that's being driven by
ego you know kind of look at me thing as
opposed to see if it does a story yeah
if it doesn't work it certainly does but
then the other side of that coin is bad
dialogue that calls attention to itself
as bad
well there's no shortage it sucks like
why are movies so bad Robert come on why
are they why have they gone right now so
bad yeah I mean August was horrific
um the tectonic plates of industry and
yeah
I have a I don't know
I don't know how long Cinema
will last as an art form
I think that in some time in the future
and I don't know how distant
um
Cinema will be like then like ballet is
today
it'll be um
uh
the minor esoteric artsy I don't know
but it won't last
um
there's a lot of
reasons film
is so expensive
um
that that they they have to they you
know they've they're going to spend 200
million dollars it's got to make a
billion to be profitable literally it's
going to make five times the investment
to to turn a profit
and and uh uh and so you've got to think
of me you know how can I get a billion
dollars worth of people to watch this
thing
um so the commercial imperative is
driven
um
by uh uh uh
the nature of things and
um
and it's not like
long for a television a long form
streaming
um you're asking people to get up out of
their house get in their car drive
somewhere Park
go to the movies at a certain time
whether it's convenient or not
um and so it's it's got to be it's got
to be a subject matter and a genre that
would be that's why I wrote this is
action that's why I wrote the book
action it is you know we're it's a it's
a Star Wars Marvel Avatar universe that
we're all living in For Better or Worse
yeah uh and and the movies that are
being made are movies at that massive
scale that are either franchise spawning
or franchise perpetuating uh they're
they're amusement park rides for for the
most part yeah um because they cost so
much they have to be that successful
which means they have to appeal to the
largest possible demographic and they
have to work in China and all of that
and you know look some of these movies
are I don't mean to be completely I love
I go see everything I like seeing bad
movies even if it's just an exercise and
trying to figure out why they're bad or
why they've made certain other choices
there's some wonderful action films I
love going to the movies and I and I
love a lot of these big movies but it is
interesting that action has be you know
you've just came out with this book
action action is the domineering genre
that monopolizes
I don't know if it's Dominique well yeah
okay there you go yeah
um um but also action merges with crime
uh well comedy now also with all these
big movies right
War and so um action and our uh mixes
with a a number of different genres
um it is it isn't all superheroes but or
whatever
um
but I wrote that for people if they if
they
want to make movies
uh if they can Master the form of action
mix it with other genres or do it in a
pure form
whether realistic or fantasy to whatever
um
that's where it is today and so I I
would hope that it that we would see
some good action because when it's good
it's great I love it yeah me too but but
um television has
sucked the the
audience away
from you know gone to the movies to see
sensitive character complex stories on
on the big screen
yeah I want to see more movies like
Michael Clayton those movies are not
going to get made for the cinema but
while the aperture is is is closing and
constricting on what is ending up uh you
know at the the Cineplex on Friday night
meanwhile in television it's expanded
you know Beyond in terms of the
opportunities I mean it's basically and
there is room for I mean you know would
Michael Clayton be made as a six hour
Netflix limited series maybe you know
but that's something I would watch too
yeah right but I want to see I like my
drama serious I don't like comedy in my
sci-fi I want my hard-boiled [__] I like
I like stuff about I like Espionage and
CIA and MI6 and all you know it's like
yeah yeah those are those are those are
long form they're not making aside from
Mission Impossible like you know you're
not going to see that in the movie
theater anymore no but it isn't only the
movies I mean there's you know novels
of course uh so more not more people
think that people have stopped reading
it's just not true more more novels are
so red and sold today they're sold and
red today than ever mm-hmm
people spend more time
you know uh with their uh on their
computer screen reading novels yeah then
uh uh than ever or listen to the audio
two more things I want to get into uh
with you and then I'll I'll release you
to your life and and one of those things
is
um
you know we've talked a lot about movies
the art and craft of writing
screenwriting Etc most people listening
to this or watching this are not
professional writers maybe they enjoy
the movies they read Etc but what so so
I guess what I want to get at is like
why should they care about story why is
story important why is thinking about
story and and taking seriously The Art
of Storytelling something that is
applicable to the average person
stories uh I think as we discussed
earlier are equipment for living
and so why do we go to the Storyteller
why do we read novels go to the theater
film television and
um it's to give us a deeper and deeper
understanding of what is absurd and
comic and right what is tragic and dark
and painful whatever to see the full
spectrum of life beyond anything we
could possibly live
you get to enter into Worlds you could
never ever know
by the thousands
and so and so the story expands your
humanity and it also enriches your
understanding of of how and why people
in the world
do the things they do to equip you to
live more more successfully
uh
the other
is that the more you read
foreign
as you read as you watch
when you go to the theater
try to um
challenge yourself
as an audience or a reader
to to read or to experience to be an
audience to something a little
higher better in some fashion more
complex more difficult than what you
just read or watched last month and
and the the wonderful thing about story
is it's a museum
if you wish you could go back and and
read the Odyssey or The Iliad
you could read the great plays written
2500 years ago in Athens
and and you can go back you know to to
the to the greatest of writers
Mark Twain and Tolstoy and you know and
uh it's all there waiting for you and
every one of those great works is as
valid today as it was when it was
written
but you're going to have to learn to
read in that language
if you're going to read Mark Twain
You're going to have to have an ear for
that that that lingo
you know Edgar Allan Poe you have to
have an ear for a whole different
um and as a result the the and then the
best of the one what I do
today
is um uh just to save myself some time
or to give myself some choices I just
pay attention to Awards
the Pulitzer Prize the Booker
Emmys why not right you mean just as a
gatekeeper to see to see who's right who
you know and I looked not for the
winners but for the nominees
and then and and it you know you can go
online and see you know what were the 10
novels nominated
if the long list for the Pulitzer for
the book of Prize or for the you know
the Whitbread and others
um and it gives you some guidance
otherwise it's just totally random right
so I do that but just you know don't
have to do that but but
um
you want to um you want them to
challenge yourself
uh to um to experience
more and more
um
fascinating
if they even if it's difficult
you know and a a really good film a
really good novel is worth seeing or
reading more than once
and and the
this just like it's the same thing the
second time you see a really fine film
it's a whole other movie sure
same thing with the novel the second
time you read a really fine novel
you can't admit you can't it also
depends on the phase of life you're in
we're we're forced to read you know a
certain set of novels you know
throughout high school and college we're
at a certain phase of Life maybe we can
connect with it maybe we can't but you
know now many years later some of those
themes that seemed irrelevant to you
then become highly resonant yes they do
yeah
um
the theater
is literally a museum
what sustains the theater and is we've
got all these great playwrights from
Tennessee Williams and Arthur Miller and
Lillian Hellman and William engine on
and on and of the 20th century Eugene
O'Neill and and the past uh Shakespeare
first amongst them and the theater
keeps um uh going keeps alive uh by
bringing them back these great plays
from the past and you see when you watch
Ibsen
or strinberg today you watch a play like
like the father and you see the ugliest
marriage in the history of marriages uh
and written in 1890
and it's fearsome and it's in it's
shocking and uh uh
funny right too right there's a it's
always it's always shocking to read
something that's quite old and and
realize that it is as of the moment as
anything and it just changes it teaches
you the lesson that everybody has to
learn yeah is it nothing changes right
human beings are human beings they're
human beings
and they're not evolving Society is but
human beings are not evil right we got
the same Hardware yeah
um
it's fascinating to me it clearly you're
you're you're you're super intelligent
and insightful and and and witty and you
have uh a sort of brash confidence about
you and you know we didn't even get into
much of your background but you know you
were an actor or you were a theater
director and a director you've you've
worked in many capacities in the
industry outside the industry you could
have to me it feels like you could have
become successful at any of these things
that you chose you could be running a
studio you could have become you know a
professional screenwriter or director a
producer Etc you make this decision to
make your life about story and I'm just
interested in like
why did you make that decision
I found
what I do best
yes I could have been I was I directed
what over 60 plays and they were very
successful and you know
um and so I could have directed in the
theater and then maybe moved on to film
television whatever uh it spent my life
doing it and I'm I'm sure I would have
been fine
I
here's what happened
I was a busy screenwriter in Hollywood I
sold every screenplay I optioned
every screenplay I wrote
one of them I've optioned
recently again for the fifth time hmm
okay it was written when in the 80s wow
and it's just been realized yeah yeah
people love it the people love it and uh
but they don't make it
um all the television that I wrote got
made and and so I could see
um my work on screen
and I recognized that yeah this is um of
quality and um and it's professional and
it's it's fine
uh but it's not ingmar Bergman
who in my judgment is the greatest
screenwriter in the history of the
movies
and then but I discovered that by
writing about lecturing and writing
about writing
um I had insights and I
could make sense of things for people
uh in ways others couldn't
and that that if I pursue that
I love doing it and if I pursue it I
could be the ingmar Bergman of writing
about writing um
and so um I I did what my instincts led
me to to do which is to become the best
at what I can do and and uh and so um
and so that's that's why I write about
writing because I love doing it and um
and it it matters apparently
um yeah
so um uh
so I'm I I remember that I made a choice
I remembered very clearly and I thought
you know I I could pursue um
um screenwriting
and I was making a living at a house in
Santa Monica you know
swimming pool and all that
um and you know maybe someday you know
who knows uh do something special
um
but
there was something about there was
teaching and the interaction with
students
it's really um it lifted my heart in the
you know to to to see their faces
while I'm lecturing and and to see light
bulbs going on as they get it I mean
they literally go they gasp at times
right yeah well it is a performance
right it is that you're writing you're
performing there's jokes you know
there's an entertainment so you know it
kind of pulls on all of those skill sets
yeah and they and they they unders it
helps them understand what they I I tell
you the old the pros who come into the
lectures
that are already you know successful
um not the least of which being people
like Akiva goldsmen and like David Bowie
took your class yes yeah it was great
that's unbelievable David did you
interact with him yeah he yeah of course
he um he was the one of the best
laughers that I've ever had I mean I the
the the lectures are
as you were pointing out you know full
of uh comedy or humor humor which and um
David Bowie just belly laughs it was
incredible he I mean literally his knees
would come up to his chin he'd laugh so
hard did you see moonage Daydream yet
have you seen the documentary about
Morgan's talking about are you yeah I've
been thinking a lot about Bowie because
that movie is is a work of Brilliance
you have is it really yeah it's
incredible
it's truly incredible it's a documentary
um
I mean it's Bowie's life but it's I
think to to coin like what Brett Morgan
the filmmaker said about it he was
trying to make a movie about David Bowie
if David Bowie was making a movie about
his life so it's a very surrealistic
kind of Sonic experience that is
non-linear in any way but but which
really conveys the sensibility of this
this artist yeah I highly recommend you
Chuck yeah
but anyway I interrupted you no no no no
no
um
uh
he you know he's the perfect example of
what I was talking about that that
um it's it's very
moving for me
to see someone get it
and you see it in their eyes in an
instant it's not you know they they're
they're
there's this look
and uh writers who have been you know
they're in their uh in the 30s and 40s
50s or whatever
um
uh often come to me uh on the break or
after and um
and they're elated
and they say I solved
my script I solved my novel at about 11
o'clock this morning because of you know
and uh and that's
yeah I lived for that yeah do you think
about Legacy at all as you're kind of
concluding this tour well there's some
books you know there's books
and um and then in all of my lectures
are recorded and um now that I've uh
this is the last this is this you know
the farewell tour and so I'm not going
to do live performances anymore
um and so now if people want
um we've recorded everything right and
uh so all of that is um uh out there for
them and um and and uh and the books
whether you know I've read all my books
for the audio version uh and um and so
there there's the you know they can read
them or you know uh listen to them
whatever
uh but but every writer who writes
fiction or non-fiction
would like to think
that what they expressed what they had
to say will live on after them
for some period of time I mean you know
not forever you know it can all be
Shakespeare but but
that it's a it's a form of uh
immortality or at least a temporal
temporary emotionality
um and so I don't uh no I don't think
about my legacy because I've already
taken care of that I wrote the books
yeah that's my legacy and they won't
live on yeah you know and I
the story is now
25 years old
the book
and it sells as much or more today than
it did 25 years ago yeah I'm not
surprised
and
um and um so um
if I had died right after I wrote story
you know it would it would still be
doing well 25 years later so I won't I
won't have any um I can't say I won't
have any regrets because I made a lot of
mistakes in life but um
but um
when I die I will die with a sense of
satisfaction I did what I set out to do
well I think that's a good beautiful
place to end it
um thank you it really was an honor to
spend time with you oh it was great fun
it was great I really enjoyed it best of
luck with uh
the end of this tour I know you got a
big day tomorrow
um so I appreciate you taking time
everybody should definitely pick up
action the art of excitement
for screen page and game and uh don't
forget the story five other people talk
about yeah you've got dialogue if you've
got character we didn't even get into
[Music]
um
uh story nomics and the power of story
and business and all of that uh maybe
you'll come back and talk to me some
more about that but crazy respect for
everything uh that that uh you've done
in the world and I think it's a great
service and it was just brilliant uh
thank you today thank you cheers
[Music]